a car engine maybe to blame for starting
a garage fire in a family's home in the
Northwest Valley well Mary Jane beliesa
shares how the family wants to spread
awareness and hopes others will be more
vigilant
this is what's left of the Siever
family's home after a garage fire broke
out Friday evening you just don't ever
expect your car to you know self-implode
and explode Cody Sharp's young daughter
alerted her father Uncle Eli and
grandmother Dory Siever after hearing a
popping noise coming from the garage
garage door it was a wall of fire it's
it looked like a dragon was in my garage
and that it hit me pretty hard and I
knew that there was no saving it so I
grabbed my daughter and left with no
time to react and just the clothes on
their back the family grabbed the pets
and ran out the front door as far as the
firefighters are concerned they they
were fairly adamant that that was that
was probably the cause and the car had
been off for hours it's not like we had
just pulled in and left the car running
I hope that's not the case I really hope
that the vehicle did not cause the
entire house to burn down because that
would be worth one and it would put a
lot of people at risk a lot of people
with a similar vehicle and this is not
an old vehicle it's not a 1990s vehicle
this is a 2019 Chevy tracks Victor
botanari owner of universal motor car
says while car engine fires are uncommon
that's most likely it's from an
electrical problem it can still happen
and a routine inspection may help other
technician to check for leaks make sure
everything gets good check the take a
quick look at the wiring harness and
things like this and I don't recommend
install aftermarket systems the family
as well it's not easy to pick up the
pieces it's easy knowing they are
thankful to have survived and still have
each other it's horrible it's hard you
know photos and and things you just
can't replace that's that's the roughest
part but everything is replaceable the
Siever family tells me the investigation
is still ongoing and will take up to a
few weeks reporting from Craig and
Rancho Mary June bellezza 8 News Now